did it take a lot of persuading to have
you appear in a cat's movie no no no it
was very easy all they had to do is ask
we all know Taylor is a real live cat
lady with Olivia Meredith and Benjamin
but did they inspire her on-screen
character Ben can you try to get her
talk to me thank you
oh no the cat that they're most like in
the movie is a cat called Jenny any dots
which rebel Wilson plays don't mess with
the crazy cat lady Oh Tay was gorgeous
and Oscar de la Renta and celebrating
her Golden Globe nominee song voices
calling although she was just snubbed by
the Oscars
hey she and boyfriend Joe Allen are
still celebrating a recent birthday and
turning that big three oh I feel like 30
is looking really good on ya that's so
nice of you thank you so much it's it's
you know I've been in my 30s for like
two days
it's been amazing loving it and 30 or
not we were part of it all as Tay had a
fangirl moment when co-star is yourself
a pass by
I love it
sorry I screamed straight into your mic
oh sorry it's fully yelled here we go
and James Corden told me the hardest
part of making the movie it's not the
singing in the dance it's the being a
cat
[Music]